the notorious former dictator Panama
Manuel Noriega died last night where you
go rule Panama with an iron fist in the
1980s he was an American ally until he
was accused of drug trafficking and
money laundering the United States
invasion in 1989 removed him from power
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn has nuria's complicated
relationship with the United States and
the law
former Panamanian dictator Manuel
Noriega was a fiery voice on the world
stage known for passionate nationalist
speeches and a lavish lifestyle born in
Panama City in 1934 and abandoned by his
parents at an early age
Noriega formally took control of his
native country in 1983 Noriega is
relationship with the United States was
complicated at one point he was a CIA
informant but later the u.s. accused him
of drug trafficking and tried to force
him from power proposal in 1988 he told
Mike Wallace on 60 minutes that the
accusations were a political ploy
general Noriega have you yourself never
profited from the transshipment of drugs
from Colombia to Panama to the United
States no god never never I directed our
armed forces to protect the lives of
American citizens in Panama and to bring
general Noriega to justice in the United
States
a year later President George HW Bush
sent troops to overthrow Noriega z'
regime he escaped the initial attack but
later surrendered to u.s. soldiers a new
breeze is blowing the day of the
dictator is over the dictator went on
trial and then to prison first in the
United States on drug charges and then
in France for money laundering in 2011
he returned to his native Panama where
he remained behind bars
and while Noriega died last night at the
age of 83 in March he fell into critical
condition after suffering a hemorrhage
after surgery to remove a brain tumor no
official cause of death has been given
Gayle thank you very much flood